como una olla presiona a sólo dos
semanas de las elecciones presidenciales
en colombia una serie de hechos marcan
el tenso panorama político que atraviesa
el país un planeado el fin de la
violencia por parte de los grupos
armados unió a más de mil indígenas de
la etnia varón asentada en la frontera
entre colombia y venezuela tras una
serie de asesinatos la comunidad
reclamaba garantías del cuidado de la
vida al mismo tiempo en que denunciaba
el crecimiento de cultivos ilícitos en
su territorio padre somos uno solo por
lo mismo estamos en apoyo en resistencia
en que sin maltratar a un barí están
maltratando a un solo pueblo barí que
habitamos en la frontera tanto de
colombia y venezuela un pulso al
presidente iván duque con mayores
dimensiones se vivió en 11 departamentos
de colombia cuando el grupo criminal
clan del golfo llevó a cabo un paro
armado que dejó 14 fallecidos y la
afectación de más de 100 municipios
después de que el gobierno extraditará a
su líder dario antonio úsuga a lesotho
miente la escena política estuvo también
marcada por la suspensión del alcalde de
la ciudad de medellín al occidente del
país por presuntamente haber participado
en política
decisión que derivó en multitudinarias
manifestaciones en temas
el futuro que merece colombia
vamos a luchar por esa democracia que
nos quieren arrebatar a la inestabilidad
política interna del país se sumó la
presión internacional tras el asesinato
del fiscal antidrogas paraguayo marcelo
pecci un crimen aún irresuelto y otro
pendiente más en la lista del gobierno
saliente